tricus du plessis and Robert Whitaker
nobody is nobody is taking duplicity no
one's giving them a chance what evidence
would you have because I think Robert
Whittaker's possibly the greatest
middleweight of all time not name Izzy
if Izzy's not there he's your reigning
world champion multiple times he's been
in so many [__] Wars this is the
driest duplicity thing he got no surgery
right because everyone talks about the
deviated eight percent his coach goes
you can only breathe eight percent it's
like
who told you that I don't give a [__]
about the numbers or whatever whatever
that's why his cardio is bad well
everyone's knock on him was his cardio
right everyone said his cardio was that
his takedown defense was pretty good I
mean if striking could get sloppy but it
got sloppy because he got tired